I met Dan originally I would think that
doobie would hit it off oh yeah for sure
I met him at a conference several years
ago and heard him tell his story and
then I just reached out to him and I
said I really want to share your story
in my podcast so I went over to his
office at ABC News a couple years ago
did the podcast he didn't know who I was
really but we just hit it off and we
don't think I'm really hit it off so
yeah I think I did his show then he came
back from a show again you know and it's
just it's cool that I mean you guys are
very different people but in a certain
respect you guys are both incredible
ambassadors of this meditation movement
that is exploding like crazy right now
it's very interesting times it's like I
mean I've been at for 45 years I've
never seen anything like this right it's
like all the resistance is all from
everybody
it's just Jim what do you what do you
attribute I have an idea of what you're
gonna say but I'm interested in your
thoughts on what you attribute the
timing to why now I think one generation
died but what they say that science
progresses one funeral at a time no I
mean a generation that was very
resistant is is passing but um I I think
there's three reasons and the first
reason is has to do with stress and the
the understanding of the impact that
what stress actually has on the brain
and nervous system and the digestive
system in the respiratory system and I
remember 20 years ago someone said they
were stressed that people made fun of
them and to try and say that there was a
link between stress and high blood
pressure was just like false science but
I think it's more than that I think
there's this desire increasing desire
that people want to and need to perform
at higher levels the whole interest in
brain potential of the brain and how you
can optimize brain so that's the first
thing and stress and on the other side
optimization of potential the second is
when it comes to stress where do we go
you know medicine cabinet where do we go
for ailments well there isn't any drug
on the market or off the market that
addresses that
we mask it and manage it and the third
is science science and more science and
shows like yours talking about
meditation making it more familiar lots
of times just hearing about it just
hearing about it mm-hmm what do you
think is reason well I think stress is
is probably number one I mean we're in
an epidemic of stress right now it's a
stress fueled culture most people when
you ask them how they're doing they're
gonna tell you they're stressed and I
think that goes hand-in-hand with
depression which is quickly becoming you
know basically our number one disability
yeah and people are starting to wake up
to the fact that the pills that they're
popping are really not working
yeah that's they're temporarily masking
symptoms that lead to side effects and
other problems compound you know when
you say stress do would you throw in
anxiety is that yeah I would I would
characterize that as a subset of stress
because that's one thing that I was I
was talking with some mother's parents
and they said who more and more people
are learning coming to learn to meditate
as faint as a whole family not just the
kid or the parent but the whole family
and they they're very concerned about
their kids because they're so anxious
about everything which is insane the
situation I know but they just they're
just they're worried about school
they're worried about how many clicks
they have the interest everything
they're just and I gave a talk in New
Jersey that I was giving a talk to some
teacher school teachers and they said
we'll come into our second grade class
secondary class if they brought 60
second graders together talk to them
about meditation that's that's an
interesting one and my first question
was how many of you feel anxious every
hand went up it's heartbreaking second
graders how many who have difficulty
sleeping half they second graders so
we're I think genuinely were in danger
danger of losing a generation I mean a
generation spans from that all the way
up to college kids and I think that's a
reason that's fueling the interest in
meditation because there's got to be
something else right then than just
medicine well it's got to be sort of not
vindicating that's the wrong word has
kind of a pejorative flair to it but
sort of
interesting for you as somebody who's
been in this for 40 years we see this
mushroom cloud you know sort of
expanding awareness and and openness to
these ideas that you've been talking
about for so long and it cuts across all
demographics it even cuts across put
left or right politics mm-hmm nobody
wants to be anxious nobody wants to be
stressed and now we know when you have
high levels of anxiety than your body
did renals secrete cortisol and when you
but cortisol is a stress hormone it
floods the hippocampus in the brain
which is a memory center so when that's
the reason why if you're anxious about
something you can't remember you know
kid goes to school and they've studied
hard and they go anxious and their
hippocampus shuts down and then they
can't remember anything and it's the
same with the athlete you know whose can
hit the jump shot over and over and over
again when they're just there's no
pressure but when they're pressure you
you freeze so I think more we understand
about the deadly impact of stress the
more people are seriously looking at
alternatives to just a pill
yeah the cortisol reduction aspect of it
is super interesting I was reading that
sleep only reduces your levels 10 to 20
percent but meditation specifically TM
can reduce at 30 to 40 is that yeah and
this is backed up by the studies that
you guys yeah published research and and
now it used to be complicated to get
cortisol levels you know you have to
take saliva but you can get it from hair
you can get it from a sample of where
and so we're looking at with kids to see
now we have a program going on in the
Chicago Public Schools
you should go into them yeah yeah so the
University of Chicago crime lab which is
a premier research institution three
years ago or two years ago was very
concerned about the number of the crime
and the violence in these toughest
schools in Chicago and so they put out
what's called an RFP a request for
proposals and to grassroots
organizations in Chicago and we have
offices David Lynch foundation has
offices all over the country so 230
organizations submitted proposals
gardening and all these different things
and we submitted something called quiet
time a proposal where you begin and end
school day with 10 to 15 minutes of
meditation and they accepted we were one
of three so they gave us $300,000 for us
a lot of money for something maybe not
it was so successful last year they
increased it to a million dollars and it
was so successful this year they
increased it to another 2.6 million
dollars and the findings have been so
marked in terms of reducing arrests
among meditating school kids improving
attendance and other school programs
have found improved academic performance
test scores closing of the achievement
gap between people of color and the
white population so huge transformation
that I really think and I never would
have thought this a few years ago I
think within a few years quiet time or
the meditation is going to be it's a
voluntary but it's gonna be offered in
schools that's remarkable wow that's
crazy
what is the sort of onboarding process
of trying to just acclimate kids in that
scenario to just being open to the idea
of even doing it to begin with well well
I I have learned and I know you do what
what type of it you do a mindfulness yes
so there are and at some point we can
talk about there's three basic after
this conversation I'm probably gonna be
signing up for my the thing is is
there's three different according to
research there's three basic types of
meditation because we know that every
experience changes the brain in a
distinct way you listen to classical
music has a different impact and if you
listen to electronic music so or you
watch a horror movie or a romantic
comedy so they know now from research
that the three basic types of meditation
based on what you do one is called
focused attention and that's a
concentration form of meditation that's
your classic clear your mind of thoughts
or concentrate on it your breath or the
mantra but it's a focus it's it's hard
work and that creates something called
thetaba let me excuse me gamma
brainwaves and particularly the front
left prefrontal cortex and that is this
is too much detail now please 20 to 50
cycles per second means you're
concentrating when your kid is studying
hard for an exam a lot of gamma bran
right you hope he's studying hard second
is called open monitoring and their many
mindfulness techniques in this and that
an observational tool where you observe
your thoughts you observe you do a body
scan you observe sensations in your body
you observe the environment you have a
dispassionate stepping back witnessing
and in that witnessing there's an
equanimity you're not caught up in the
moment that creates something called
theta brainwaves which is a pre onset
dream that's six to eight cycles per
second and the third is transcend itself
transcending and that is no effort
completely effortless and that is
accessing not minding the thoughts but
accessing a field of calm that already
exists within everyone then the
hypothesis so perhaps this would be a
good moment to just define
Transcendental Meditation in the context
of that and what it is about that
practice that allows you to enter that
self-transcendent stage so I like to use
an example of an ocean we are stuck
you're on a little boat and you're stuck
on the middle of the Pacific Ocean and
you get these humongous waves 30 40-foot
high waves and you could think the whole
ocean is enough people but if you could
do a cross-section of the ocean out
there you'd realize you got these little
itty-bitty 30-foot waves but the ocean
in reality is over a mile deep and while
the surface of the ocean may be
turbulent the depth of the ocean is by
its nature silent and that's analogous
to the mind so the surface of the mind
is this active thinking mind got a got a
got a monkey mind all that and every
human being thinks that sometimes I'd
like to have some inner calm submitter
quiet some inner ease some inner silence
some inter focus and the operative word
there is inner and the question is is
there such a thing as an inner and if so
how do you get there
so Rick when we talk about
transcendental meditation as I said a
moment ago we hypothesize because
there's no belief there's no philosophy
here the deep within you and your wife
and every other person you know and
everyone in the world right now there's
a level of the mind deep within a
transcendent level of the mind that is
already calm quiet peaceful and yet the
source of our creativity intelligence
happiness and transcendental meditation
gives effortless access to that how
should I answer this yeah how because
I'm thinking when you're describing the
other the other methodology of kind of
noticing your thoughts and being the
dispassionate neutral observer of the
meanderings of the mind that probably
best describes my experience so what do
we do so in that in that it's a
cognitive process it's it's attending
and adjusting to you could say the waves
so focused attention is stop the waves
the ideas and thoughts or you're on the
surface you're on the surface and the
same with this when you're stepping back
and observing the thoughts or obtuse
surface in Transcendental Meditation we
recognize or we identified that there's
a vertical dimension to the mind that we
feel things deeply you love your wife
deeply you don't want to do something
profoundly there there's that there's
that feeling of silently an athlete
you're an athlete there must be moments
of the zone sure that goes way beyond
what's up here and there's just this
pervasive silence and so that quiet calm
that we access in during meditation
Transcendental Meditation and I'll tell
you how we do that effortlessly so other
approaches to meditation see thoughts or
the wandering mind is not the enemy but
sort of the the obstacle to a calm mind
so if you could control the mind it's
always a monkey mind it just wanders and
you've got to rein it in or you've got
to give more space between thoughts or
and Maharishi Mahesh Yogi who was a
physicist it became a great meditation
teacher his insight was the mind is not
wandering aimlessly your mind is not
just a monkey mind your mind is in
search of something more satisfying you
sit in a room and you listen to some
wretched music and some beautiful music
comes on in the other room your
attention is drawn to that music you
bring two books on vacation and one book
is terrible and you can't read it
another book is great absorbed in it for
hours it is not people say well it's an
acquired skill to meditate to do this
mindfulness it's not an acquired skill
to listen to the most beautiful music
you've heard in your life
it's not an acquired skill to see the
most beautiful sunset you've ever seen
in your life you're drawn to that and
the idea or the hypothesis again I use
that term is that inside of everyone in
that transcendent level of the mind is a
field of satisfaction quiet bliss peace
happiness all the people have talked
about it forever in Transcendental
Meditation you learn how to give the
attention I know this is abstract but
you learn how to give the attention of
the mind in inward direction like you
want to teach a child how to dive you
say honey stand like this bend over like
that rest is automatic
there's no forcing gravity takes over so
when you learn TM from a teacher you
learn how to just allow the attention of
your mind to be drawn inward and without
any effort as a matter of fact any
effort stops the process without any
effort your mind is just gently settles
down and when that happens then you have
alpha-1 brainwaves completely different
than mindfulness and I want to talk a
little bit more of that some of the
other brain research your body gains
this deep state of rest cortisol levels
are reduced and you feel rejuvenated do
I think there's a role if for other do I
think TM is the only way of course not
mmm-hmm of course not but in TM so what
I gather from this description is that
on some level it's about attenuating
that effort right because the mind is
always searching - do you give it
something more satisfying to go for if
if you if you're going if you're sitting
in front of a TV and you've got 20
horrible shows you're just clicking you
can but if there's a great and someone
says oh my god you're lost can you get
you terrible you can't stop so that's
the mind with nothing satisfying on that
horizontal level nothing is that
satisfying but you transcendent just
beneath the waves and increasingly so
there's just that calm that silence that
is very attractive and how do you access
that and that's where the the personal
instruction TM is never taught in just
out of a book because if I teach you or
a teacher teaches you it's how do you
have that innocence how do you just let
your attention
turn within and then afterwards people
go oh my god I had no idea
mm-hmm and 20 minutes goes by quickly
not like painfully so then how what is
your perspective then on on all of these
apps that are popping up that are
introducing people to meditation they do
that the you know see yeah but on some
level I mean I would imagine there's
good in that right you're sort of
co-opting this device of distraction and
and and I think people to use it in a
more volatile and I teach a lot of
people who've done headspace or calm or
these things and it was a big help and
then they did it for awhile and they
said well is there something more
because mine looks for something more
right so I think their entry entry and
for if it works for a person it works
for a person but but there's something
about that transcendence yeah and even
we've tried teaching it online or
something like that there's something
about you're in the room with the
teacher one-to-one for that first hour
and then I'm with it and there's nobody
else in the room it's and then when I'm
with that person and it can be yourself
it could be CEO of a company it could be
a professor it could be a homeless kid
and they have the same experience that
every one of them can transcend equally
well right and and the distinguishing
thing here or one of the distinguishing
things here is that rather than focusing
on your breath or noticing your thoughts
as they come and go your intention is on
this mantra that you with you it's
actually the mantra is the vehicle the
difference is you're sitting in that
you're sitting in Los Angeles and it's
hot and horrible mantras like a car that
takes you to the beach so the car is not
the end in itself concentrating on a
mantra the mantra is a vehicle that
takes you to the ocean the mantra is a
vehicle that takes you to your inner
calm so the transformations that take
place in TM and the changes in brain is
not from the repetition of the mantra is
from accessing those realms within those
calm settled levels of the mind which we
occasionally rarely access you know
again when you're running or when you're
listening to music or you hold a newborn
baby in your arms and time slips away or
you're with your partner and there's
just a moment of unity it's got nothing
to do with breath
thought anything it's just silence so
let's uh that's interesting let's track
back to how you got into this to begin
with
how it goes back there like no
flowerpower age in 1968 at Berkeley
right well the funny thing is is I tell
people when you think of what a
meditation teacher would be traditional
I ain't that guy no I know that's why we
were talking about Dan Harris like how
iconic huge sort of like him yeah so I
grew up I was born in Washington DC I
grew up in the San Francisco Bay Area my
father didn't this won't be long when I
was 2 years okay he goes long as you
want by the way
so my father will for you're putting
your audience to sleep
my father was in World War two he was
injured war veteran he got a job in San
Francisco at the VA hospital fort Miley
so we moved out at the age of three and
I had a very political family my parents
talked politics all the time and I you
know debated issues and I tell people
that when I was growing up I knew I was
a Democrat before I knew I was Jewish
yeah that's we just talked about that
all the time now I vote for the person
not to party but and I had I remember in
high school I worked for Bobby Kennedy
50 years ago today I was working for
Bobby Kennedy to be to get the
Democratic National you know the the
part presidential nomination and I had a
column in my high school newspaper in
Marin County and in what redwood high
school and it was I was a co-editor of
my paper and that column was called the
gripes of Roth uh-huh so that was his
sixty that was 68 he was complaining
about everything so Bobby Kennedy he was
assassinated and it like destroyed my
life
well I I he was my hero he was he was
whatever as a 17 year old kitten I went
to Berkeley in October September 1968
with the intention of going to law
school
to become a u.s. senator like Bobby
Kennedy I want to change the world I was
interested in social transformation I
was interested in equal access
you know just everybody should have an
equal shot it shouldn't matter what
gender what color you get an equal what
you do with is your own doing so I go to
Berkeley and it's insane right and how
to just be but in a sane and I wasn't
crazy person I wasn't a druggie I was
just a guy who when activists who wanted
to do good and suddenly I realized that
politics wasn't gonna heal the soul of
the country just gonna be more divisive
so then I thought what am I gonna do and
my mother was an educator so I thought
all right educational curriculum and
work with kindergarteners and and build
up from there it's interesting that you
had that reaction because it could have
gone the other way and just confirmed
your resolve to get even deeper into
politics it was too much compromise by
that time there was this thing of I had
to be absolutely true to myself you know
what was most important was authenticity
and I was already I saw on both sides
left and right too much violence too
much destruction on the left destruction
towards women on the I mean just
destructive behavior and so I parallels
with what's going on right now yeah and
we have an office in on Capitol Hill the
foundation who I teach people on Capitol
Hill we can talk about that yeah but so
I'm I'm stressed and I had a friend who
was like a normal guy who said you
should learn Transcendental Meditation
and I said first of all wasn't it word
in my vocabulary and I also said I got
enough issues of my own religion and he
said no you don't have to believe in
anything cuz I'm a skeptical pretty
enough to believe in anything try it and
I learned it and it was so marked it was
because I tried other things and it was
such a deep relaxation in such a
transcendent moment completely awake I
didn't go anywhere and one of my first
thoughts was oh I'd like to teach this
to inner-city school kids wasn't I want
to get enlightened yeah I mean from from
the way you described it in the book
which I love by the way I just got I'm
just started it but I skip to the last
chapter to read you know where you can
tell your personal story it seemed like
you had that
response right from the get-go like this
was from the very very first experience
with it and I don't it was an innocent
sort of thought it wasn't like oh now in
my five-year plan for my life I was in
this gap politic I wanted to make a
difference in the world that was classic
ventures 68 behavior politics wasn't it
education I thought okay instead of
sweeping reform I'll do one at a time
and then I thought the thought was oh
I'd like to kids little kids could use
this they could they could use this so
it was one of my first thoughts people
learn to meditate oh I want to get
enlightened what am i thought right it's
interesting how the light switch just
went on and in that moment you just you
just knew immediately June 1969 so it's
like all those years later yeah 49 years
later and it began with it you were
working in an ice-cream shop seems
pretty chill no no there was a guy was
working it if anybody your listeners
know Berkeley on the north side of
Berkeley is a Swensons ice cream is
still there probably it is yeah and on
the south side they had one near the
dorm and a top dog they had so I'm work
I used to work there and there was this
guy named Peter Stevens who was the one
chill guy who was normal who wasn't
crazy and it was a kind person and he
was working on a master I mean he had a
master's anyway I went to see him one
night at 10 o'clock in the middle of
studying to get ice cream which only a
kid can do I think and ice cream at 10
for helping my studies and I said
where's Peter he's in the back
meditating and it was like what what
because a meditation if I'd even heard
it was just kind of strange when he was
not that way so I asked him about it and
he said I'm not gonna tell you if you
want it there's a TM Center across town
so I went to a lecture and I remember at
the end of the lecture was made sense
and I said to the woman how much of this
stuff do I have to believe in for it to
work because I'm very skeptical and she
held up a piece of chalk and she said
you don't have to believe in gravity for
the chalk to fall right opted same with
meditation was this before the white
album white album was is very
interesting that was October 68 right
right now this is being recorded
February 11
12 yeah and and the Beatles had just
arrived or just arriving in India to be
with Maharshi mm-hmm and so 50 years ago
they were there writing the White Album
and then they recorded it and I think
there came out in September oh right
right as you're being introduced to this
and then fast-forward to you going to
spend time with him in Spain and 72 all
right became a teacher loved it
Maharishi was uh had been trained as a
physicist in in college and unlike how
he was portrayed in the press he was he
was just a wise man who had smart new
physics and he was surrounded by Nobel
laureates and he was talking about
there's this field inside that anyone
doesn't matter what your religion or
philosophy it's there and one of the
first things he did when he came to the
United States as he went to UCLA and
Harvard Medical School and said you
gotta study this the effects because
look at me no one's gonna trust me I'm a
guy from India wearing a dhoti right but
he became a mainstream cultural figure
after the Beatles went and visited
visited with him and then there's all
this controversy swirling around
whatever may or may not have happened
there but my understanding is that you
know this guy learned how to do this
from the great guru dev yeah and you
know this comes from the Vedas and the
Upanishads and it was sort of bestowed
upon him by Gurudev like look go forth
into the world and and you know be
amongst the people and you know
propagate this message for the
betterment of all and you know it's kind
of when you think of 1958 and 59 you had
Sputnik II I mean you had just the world
was so materialistic it was none of this
there was no yoga there was this Matic
Time magazine read recently did some
retrospective and said ma Hershey was
responsible not only for bringing
meditation but yoga and even organic for
all that stuff that came out at that
time came from that period and he built
up a huge organization nonprofit
organization and one of the most amazing
things is I meet a lot of interesting
people who I'm not we don't mean
celebrity types but I got to
no Paul and Ringo quite well and I
taught member of their kids and that was
quite a yeah tell me about that well
okay so was I had to tell you either
stay with me so there was all this talk
about John Lennon and you know he didn't
like right there was a little bit of a
falling out that's right right turned
out it was like for an hour
but it got in the press because I was
teaching I was in Sam I was in New York
City and I got a phone call one
afternoon about four or five years ago
and it was his young man on the phone
and he said I'd like to learn to
meditate and he didn't give me his name
is fine so we just thought what why do
you want to learn he said well you know
I'm I'm a little anxious and my friends
thought it would be very good for me and
they were talking and he said well
actually the reason I want to learn is I
grew up in my both my parents meditated
from when I was born my whole life twice
a day they meditated and it was great
for them and I think it'd be good for me
and I said oh do I know them and he said
John and Lennon and my mom Yoko right I
said yeah kind of know them yeah but at
the point that they meditated they
meditated together so what was in the
press was just sort of nonsense and Paul
and Ringo continued to meditate and
trying to support maharshi's work
they've been big big I run this
foundation which is brought it we're
gonna talk about yeah but but George was
like the main guy George leaves all in
yeah from the beginning and he brought
the others and George was also very
close I mean they just saw Maharshi for
who he was a person who was a simple man
not a self aggrandizing but had learned
from his teacher this meditation
technique of effortless transcending it
was very annoying when he started
traveling in India saying that this was
good for everyone there's no caste just
everyone some people like the hierarchy
and the elites and he built it until
it's now thousands of centers all over
the world and what was it like when you
were studying underneath him and in that
guy's presence there was one time I
remember to this day it was like 1975
and I was in a meeting where you had
Maharshi was in the middle and he was
sort of overseeing this conference on
religion he had all these great
religious leaders on one side and all
these great Nobel laureates on the other
and they were just talking about these
universal principles of
and it struck a chord and I thought this
is a conversation you could have had
during the times of Plato or if you
don't allow to anybody anytime wise
people without an agenda wise people who
are just interested in exploring and
plumbing the deepest truths of life
whether it's from perspective of science
or religion or philosophy or art or
music and very universal feeling
timeless yeah is there is there
something specific that you think you
gleaned from from learning from him
directly that you could have not learned
from you know reading his teachings in a
book or I think the way is good because
I was around him at different times for
over 40 years so I saw him in 1970 at a
course in Humboldt State College and
then trained with him in 1972 to become
a teacher with thousands of other people
and then periodically over the years for
meetings and conferences and the way he
was the the way when I was around in the
way he sort of managed me is like a lot
of room a lot of space use your own
creativity figured out never told me
what to do you know though I went to my
guru and he took never just use your
common sense be true to yourself those
lessons be true to yourself listen to
yourself and there was one lesson that I
heard that I've never forgotten where a
person a reporter one time asked
Maharishi they said what's the single
most important quality any person needs
to have in order to live healthy have a
better chance of living a healthy
successful happy life and you know I'm
thinking love compassion and he said
discernment hmm the ability you have to
have a quiet intellect and a good
intellect and a good intuition how do I
spend about my choices who do I spend my
life with
what do i what do I eat where do I
invest my time because those choices are
what brings back happiness those deep
simple choices so I never forgot that
yeah it's interesting I mean I think
discernment goes hand-in-hand
and with intentionality yes
and sort of sits at the opposite end of
the spectrum from reactivity which is
the sort of function of the monkey mind
you know we're all living our lives
reflexively reactively and it's that
white space in between you know what's
going on in your head and the behaviors
that you choose to engage that define
what your life is going to look like
right and discernment means that that
that moment that moment of pause and and
perhaps deeper reflection that allows
you to make a better choice for yourself
on the ancient meditation texts they
call the bhagavad-gita they call about
like a flame in a windless place so the
intellect is just nothing outside you
know you're not emotion you're just like
calm and clear and you just see into the
reality of things and they also used to
say an enlightened person he defined as
a cool mind and a warm heart uh-huh and
I like that so you have that you know
when LED intellect that just sees into
the reality is not swayed but also has a
huge compassion and kindness and loving
kindness for others mm-hmm yeah I've
noticed in people that have well honed
discernment that they almost appear
omniscient you know like they can see so
clearly where they need to go and what
they need to do and what's right and
what's wrong
like there's no hesitation in their in
their perspective and a truly you know I
mean the purpose of meditation or
Transcendental Meditation
is not just to get rid of the stress
that you get from driving on the FDR the
405 it was always full you know
self-realization I mean they talked
about that or enlightenment and now
today when you're looking at the
research on people who've been
meditating for five years 10 years 20
years 30 40 50 years you start seeing
connections in the brain that start in
meditation but because of the neuro
plasticity of the brain those
connections that communication between
the front of the brain and the back of
the brain and left and right hemispheres
lasting in activity so you don't lose
resolute intellect you don't lose that
that kindness and compassion
you're not overshadowed by anything
small outside it's that's why I mean
originally Transcendental Meditation was
the domain of the warrior classes
because you couldn't fight with anger
revenge pettiness any of those things
and you didn't want to fight it was a
failure if you fall right yeah that's
super interesting as a natural skeptic
how do you personally reconcile you know
on the one hand the kind of you know the
Vedic traditions that are steeped in
Hinduism and and the like and whatever
you know you may have learned from
Maharishi directly versus the scientific
studies and the kind of predicament of
the modern human and what they're trying
to deal with as a communicator of this
well first of all Maharshi repeatedly
emphasized that vedic knowledge
predates him into vincent's like 2500
years old that vedic knowledge has no
geography has no culture has no it's
just knowledge it's just like the theory
of relativity is not a german-jewish
reality because Einstein discovered it
Einstein was a voice in a culture at a
time
who cognized that and I think that Vedic
that when you talk about Ayurveda that's
not a religious thing that if I eat this
food it strengthens my immune system or
if I take that herb it's just or if I
bend this way and Bend that way so he
really went out of his way to really say
I've been someone used the example if
you saw a catholics girl school kids
doing jumping jacks jumping jacks aren't
catholic it's just being used so I would
say that Hinduism or Buddhism adopted
these practices but in their essence
they're devoid of all that philosophy
all that sort of cultural baggage and I
think and Maura she also said that every
single thing if it's true from Ayurveda
or step out you know sapota Veda which
is like Fung Shui
it will be able to be documented by
modern science there's not a division
right
so you so I'll that rezulin resonated
with me yeah yeah I get it I get it so
you you start experiencing the benefits
of this immediately and what what I
think is interesting about you is you
know there's a lot of hype about all the
fancy people that you teach you know
like that that makes for good clickbait
or what-have-you and there's some super
interesting people that you've had the
opportunity to teach meditation to but I
think what's really cool about about
what you do is that your heart is really
in trying to help people that fall
outside of this elitist rubric and it's
something that you did immediately like
your dad was volunteering at San Quentin
right and that was kind of like the
first place that you took this yeah I
don't know it's just whether it's just
sort of a hopeless sixties idealist or
something but I've never been from the
beginning when I learned this I always
thought this is something that should be
made available to everyone there should
be no obstacle whether money or access
or time this is something that should be
every human beings birthright and
particularly since the way I was brought
up with my parents all whether it's
prisons or working in the schools in
Marin City which was such a diversion
where you have Sausalito on the one side
which is this fancy-schmancy and then
just across the highway Marin City which
was the at the time used the term ghetto
you know in 1968 and I was always drawn
ended to that to bring to those kids and
not because I'm this do-gooder who has
to work out something and I want praise
it's like here's a tool use it on your
own you know it takes me an hour a day
over four days to teach it to you it's
yours buddy or whoever take it make what
you want of it and that's always has
been my interest in and the funny thing
is all these different people because I
get asked well how about this person I
thought okay let's say I taught thirty
well-known people I've taught thousands
of inners know no inner cities young
kids veterans you know regular moms and
dads but it's just one of those things
but I don't mind because those people
that I get to teach well they become
mouthpieces they become ambassador
in their own right and they're good
people Tom Hanks is a really good person
you know Jerry Seinfeld very good person
and they on their own I don't ask them
on their own they say how can I help
and so they help raise the fund so that
we can bring this to people who need it
so you you have this opportunity then to
begin to really scale this when when you
end up connecting with David Lynch right
who I would imagine some of you probably
know for a long time but you guys
formalize your relationship in this
foundation that you created when in 2005
5005 yeah uh-huh so tell me a little bit
I mean like I'm obsessed with this guy
like what one of the most unique
creative voices walking planet Earth I
mean what in what a what an original
human being David Lynch is so how did
this is more true to himself than
anybody I've ever met more true to
himself most self-referral I look to him
as a as a sort of a reference point he's
an original I mean all those things are
just sort of but the best thing about
him is he has a huge heart yeah you know
he started a lot of people start
foundations and they disappear and they
put their name you know David traveled
around the world he's been meditating
since 1973
the beginning of a racer hit he traveled
around the world many times in support
of meditation and he wrote a book and he
did a a catching the big catching the
big fish you should listen to on audio
the only ways it is like yeah don't read
it no no I hear him breathe it it is
priceless unbelievable so what I've
learned from him is originality and he
always says in life you have to have
final cut you've got final cut
yeah his conviction his conviction for
his own creative voice is unparalleled
no there's no pun like Vermont yeah yeah
completely no and he it's just final cut
you just can't he said if the painter
was painting something
and at the very end some guy in a suit
came in and said I want some blue in
there you didn't get out of here right
well why can somebody do that when
you're working on a film and he said his
only biggest mistake that he ever made
was in with the movie dune where he gave
up final cut to Dino De Laurentiis man
and he said a disaster
yeah disaster and he said you died two
deaths when you give up he said if it
fails and you did your best
fine but if it fails and you weren't
true to yourself it's impossible to deal
with so what do you think is what is it
about him that that makes him such a
powerful fearless he's fearless he's
fearless in his life like all he loves
and is fascinated by let's just say a
hamster this great little baby hamster
growing up to his full life and he's
just as fascinated by the laws of nature
to watch that wolf that dead hamster
decay
know it sounds crazy I saw a video once
where he took like a raw piece of meat
and put it on the floor in his garage
and he just filmed it or you know I
wanted to talk about it well he says its
laws of nature its laws of nature that
create and the laws of nature that
destroy but there's those are laws of
nature with that little hamster than is
dead and so why is it okay oh you know
there's light in a day there's light and
darkness that's a full day why is it
that I'll only look at this and not look
at that and so when some people have
called him on you know his films and
he's a meditation guy in who what's mr.
bliss doing making films like this he
said first of all an artist reflects the
world around him or her and we changed
the world I'll change my art and the
other thing that is great that he says
is you don't have to suffer to show
suffering you know like you don't have
to die to do a death scene just have to
be empathetic and intuitive and be able
to show scenes but he's not he's
fearless I'll be watching a film with
him and my natural inclination when
something really horrible comes on this
is just sort of like glam
away and he's just and not in a weird
way he just loves the whole thing right
and one thing he said someone was on him
about his films and he said have you
read the Old Testament you know a
million times worse than everything I'm
doing well he's funny yeah he's really
funny
I'd love to get him on your show somehow
I would I would kill for that that would
be amazing and what I loved about the
way you described how you created this
foundation was how easy it was like you
just said hey let's do this and he was
like okay and then it just kind of
happened without any grand design or
plan it was like it had been my desire
for a very long time you know I've
worked in businesses and I worked in
schools but always for 30 years teaching
TM I've taught TM for 45 46 almost 46
years doing all this but always was kids
kids kids kids kids and so at one point
is just I was reading about the horrors
that children face in schools and you
can focus on the under-resourced schools
but it's really across the board we're
losing a generation and so I just had
built up and I just said David I really
want to start it we should really start
this foundation and he said fine and I
said I want to put it in your name I
don't think he thought anything was
gonna come from he said fine and then I
said can I write a press release about
it and he said fine and then two days
later was like in papers all over the
world and I say in the book he called
what he called him he said what's a
501c3 so now today you guys are I mean
you have millions of dollars in grant
money that are being allocated to not
only helping kids but what I love is
you're helping you're helping inmates
and prisons and also specifically
veterans with PTSD I think it's super
interesting so can you talk a little bit
about this program I mean when you look
at at veterans and I've taught many I
mean when you took it look at the
inmates and they've done research and
across the board almost every one of
them has suffered some trauma in their
sustained or moments of huge trauma in
their life nobody just kills somebody
for no good reason but if you grow up in
a violent community and they call it AC
E which is acute childhood experiences
which means some traumatic experience
and if a child has three or four of them
at an early age they see the father beat
the mother they witnessing then they are
on a pipeline to prison because it just
skews them and when we bring the meted
Transcendental Meditation again because
the body gets this deep rest it heals
the body in a profound way it uh knots
those stresses and there's research that
shows a 50% reduction in recidivism
rates with when inmates leave prison
eighty percent of all crimes are repeat
offenders because they some kid at the
age of eighteen ends up in an adult
prison its penitentiary for doing
something bad and then it's like a
college for criminals
you know criminal behavior so fifty
percent reduction in recidivism rates
when it comes to veterans my dad was a
veteran I grew up around veterans those
are a completely different story a lot
of these were just kids 17 years old 18
years old
they go off to Iraq or wherever they go
and then one day there's a there on a
tank and everybody gets killed but them
and they come back like a shell of a
human being and they can't sleep for
months because of nightmares and cold
sweats and then they learn to meditate
and it's not an exaggeration to say that
within a few days the first thing that
happens is because they've gotten as
deep rest they start sleeping through
the night and we have a stud the
Department of Defense just to lock this
down to some science the Department of
Defense several years ago gave us 2.4
million dollars to do a study on the
effects of TM on post-traumatic stress
on post 9-11 veterans comparing it to
what's called prolonged exposure which
is the gold standard of treatment and
the study showed that TM was as good if
not a lot better than prolonged exposure
for healing reducing symptoms and one of
the big differences is prolonged
exposure is they show videos or films of
people get tanks
blown-up me and that they don't the
veterans don't like doing that and they
love meditating long answer to a short
quiz on board who's seeing this and is
willing to fund it to the tune of
millions of dollars which is huge
progress especially in the face of the
opioid crisis that we're looking at
right now and how many of these poor
veterans who come back and are suffering
are just hopelessly addicted to these
pills that are just you know creating
wreaking havoc well I think one reason
why a Doran's like TM like anybody does
is a year and a half ago they were
healthy they were like it's not like
they've been living and brightening up
some they were just normal kids and then
all of a sudden they're not and they
know it and they're embarrassed because
they are weakened and they're taught as
a you know a military personnel to be
tough and not to show any weakness and
so rather than seek out help
it was internalized and they try suicide
you know 21 veterans commits because
they can't admit and when they go to the
VA if they get diagnosed and people
don't notice if they get diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress it's like a black
mark on their record they can't get a
job as a police as a security guard they
can't even get a job as a crossing guard
at a public school so a chilling effect
on even resurrecting it to begin with
and the Orioles they're given a handful
of drugs and they're drugged out in
their mind that's not what they want
they remember still two years ago and
they were fine and the beauty about TM
is they learn a technique and they just
go you never see them again
they just meditate on their own they
can't come back for follow-up but they
don't need to yeah I think I read also
in the prison context at some prison you
taught TM and the the prison guard or
the warden said to you I've never seen
these guys sit together in the same room
quietly like with their eyes shut like
he just couldn't even believe it yeah
that was at San Quentin prison where I
was there when we were working with
men on death row and men who were in
shackles you know so when they came till
you learned one to one from a teacher
and so one to one in order to do that he
was in Chains and shackles because a
violent person and every one of them
because it's not hard it's the navin
that guy it's his nature of the mind to
be drawn to something more satisfying
and so they go for it so people say well
why they take a drug because for that
moment there's a relief from the pain
it doesn't say afterwards but there's a
relief for the pain and so they have
that experience you don't it's not an
acquired skill and you teach them to
turn the attention within and
effortlessly everything happens the
transcendence takes place on its own
size don't and it doesn't require a
belief system it works whether you're
skeptical of it or not
no you don't have to be I don't have
what if I didn't believe in gravity I'm
still sitting here
I don't have to believe in electricity I
can turn on a light switch yeah that's
like how the 12 steps work whether you
are dismissive of them or not if you do
them they will work I actually like it
when you know it's often one person in a
partnership one person learns to
meditate and then oh I really want my
husband to learn I really want my wife
to learn but she's so negative and she's
so skeptical and you know she won't
believe it and I say I don't care right
if they want to come and and take four
days and I say to them do the four days
hour a day if you don't like it after
the four days don't do it you know
there's no there's no it's there's no
loss here try it and if people say well
I do mindfulness or I do be pasta and I
say we have to stop siloing you know I
do this and therefore I don't do that
there's many tools in a toolbox and
these three different approaches focused
attention open monitoring mindfulness
and transcending they have different
outcomes they have different purposes
you don't say well i'm i eat protein so
I don't eat leafy greens right it's like
it's a balanced life yeah what if has
there been long-term studies on the
impact of this on people that struggle
with addiction there was a study that
just came out big problem with addiction
is relapse so they go away for a 30 day
8 zillion dollar something but they go
away they get off alcohol or drugs or
any other addiction food sex and then it
was a hyper proportion relapse and so
they're just a study just came out it
was conducted at Avery Road which is a
alcohol treatment facility in Bethesda
and the findings showed that in a
control group that the people who were
not meditating every one of them
relapsed and the people who did who were
meditating regularly there was like a
60% reduction they didn't relapse wow
that's amazing like that the house big
was the control group it was it was at
phase 1 clinical trials like 40 and 40
now we're going for a phase 2 clinical
trial which will be 200 and then the
third which we really want to do is a
thousand yeah my goal is highest best
toughest most rigorous research so you
can with largest numbers independent so
you can we can change public policies
and it goes back to my desire from the
beginning was the effect public policy
and if if the VA is paying gazillions of
dollars for medication will why not pay
a fraction of that for meditation right
yes in their economic interest yeah
invest in that as a viable alternative
yeah I mean I'm I'm in recovery I'm in
silver for a while but um you love this
yeah no yeah I do and I think you know
as somebody whose life has been
transformed by the 12 steps of which
meditation is one my perspective as a
member of that community is that that
step which involves meditation kinda
gets the it kind of doesn't get the
attention that it deserves it's part of
it but the meditation there isn't really
any kind of folk you don't know what to
do yeah do it actually do it
60-seconds yeah no one tells them how to
do it and so it doesn't really stick and
so it doesn't really become an integral
practice in that recovery equation for
most people you wouldn't just if you had
a physically I mean wouldn't
I'll just go online and see what they
tell me to do you know you go to an
expert you go to a person who's a proper
diagnostician who could prescribe
something that's proven and I think the
same way is with mine we we shouldn't be
so casual we should do research you know
meditation there's a lot of hippie
dippie stuff there's some cheap stuff
but there's also some substantive stuff
and learn from a teacher who knows what
she or he is doing you know you have a
certified teacher one of the big
problems and I have a lot of friends in
the mindfulness field and Sharon
Salzberg was telling me that she said
problem with mindfulness now is they
lost their brand anybody can say they're
doing whatever and so science doesn't
know what it is if you do a mindfulness
program at a school in Spokane what are
you doing in same circle
yeah there's no control whereas with TM
it's specific it's it's absolutely
precise and the training program is high
level of certification right and it
involves doing 20 minutes of this
practice twice a day yes actually once
in the morning for 20 minutes you get up
20 minutes earlier and you people say
I'm not gonna give up my time right my
sleep and say no no it's better than
sleep it's deeper than sleep and then
sometime in the afternoon or early
evening before dinner so the morning is
like rejuvenating and you have a high
level of energy that takes you sustained
so you don't need multiple cups of
coffee and that sort of thing and makes
you more resilient and then you do it at
the end of the day to sort of wash off
the stresses of the day whatever you've
picked up and be more present with your
partner with what you're doing in the
evening and sleep much better at night
so traditionally for thousands of years
it used to be Dawn had done at dawn and
dusk but it was first thing morning and
afternoon do you ever miss yeah of
course yeah I mean it I try not to and
while you're human
most people say I don't have time or I
don't know how I'm gonna make the time
but like myself like a good alcoholic
I'm like will more must be better right
when I was talking to Dan Harris he told
me that he's experimenting right now
with meditating 2 hours a day because he
wants to just see you know like he wants
to like he wants to come to you you do
yeah well I would imagine
would just to see like what that what
would happen if he does he must be
missing his wife
I was actually no we can close but I was
actually talking to this businessman and
in New York who was with his 12 year old
son and they were sent by his wife was
meditating and I think the wife took
this son aside and gave him some tips on
what to say so the husband was saying
you know I'd like to learn how to do it
I don't think I can do it because my
mind is so busy but I don't have the
time I just don't have the time 20
minutes - I sit down all the time so the
kid said dad there's 1440 minutes in a
day you don't have 40 minutes and then
this is where the mom came in for
self-care uh-huh so and the fact is it
has to be a priority the trick the
trajectory the trajectory that we are
all on as a society as a culture as
individuals is not sustainable it's just
not sustainable we're falling apart and
so this is an intervention this is my
own intervention I'm going to take 20
minutes from my morning find it get up
earlier I'm going to take 20 minutes in
the afternoon for myself and then the
rest of the world will adjust and the
nice thing about this is so many people
who come say I could never close my eyes
for two minutes much less twenty and
because this meditation is so enjoyable
the experience is so satisfying 20
minutes flies by just flies by I think
even beyond that there is a weird
spiritual equation that takes place
where time bends in on it on itself and
because by virtue of doing a practice
like this you suddenly have more time
because you're more efficient under day
under more focused you get more things
done
there's no procrastination and suddenly
that list of to do's shrinks
precipitously compared to what it looked
like when you're not practicing this
sort of and can I close by just giving
to the brain research on this so
everybody wants to be more creative
everybody nobody wants to feel there's
your stag they want to grow they don't
want to feel they're stagnant or stuck
in a relationship in their own feeling
inside and their job
they want to grow and so a lot of very
creative people I teach a lot of very
creative people and so I was curious
what's the brain mechanism of a creative
what's a creative brain and they say
that there's three they used to think
that there was regions of the brain
which govern creativity oh the right
hemisphere that's the creative side and
then though they are the sciences it's
not it's not regions its networks its
connections and there's three networks
that are involved in the creative
process the first is called the
prefrontal cortex which is the executive
network the executive control center
that's focused concentration judgment
planning that's attention focus then the
other element opposite of that is called
the imagination network or the clunky
name default mode Network and that part
of your brain gets awakened when you
take a hot shower go for a run we're not
like in front of the computer typing and
figuring it out then there's a third
part of the brain called just say it's
the what navigates it shuts down when
you need to focus it shuts down the the
imagination center and when you are sort
of blue skying it shuts that down the
the attention sorry this is complicated
but a creative person and meditation
develops this has both networks
functioning at the same time because
those neural pathways are communicating
it's right increased if that's rising so
that means you can focus but not lose
the right the wandering to open the
imagination and you can have the
imagination but not lose the ability to
make it real huh I'm sold Bob Roth loves
with unity oh yes next I'd be honored to
teach you no it'd be great all right I
would love to take you up on that Irish
when I come back and I'm gonna spend
more time in LA I would like to teach
you all right well thank you sir I know
you got to get going
Lynch yeah well say hello to him for me
I'm going to the invitation is wide open
for him to come on the podcast anytime
the new book is great strength and soul
in stillness so just came out February
8th right are very sick so brand new on
the shelf so it's very accessible you
can read this and like
two days not only cool our to out yeah
it's super easy and the best way the
best place for people to find out a
little bit more about you and your work
David Lynch foundation org or TMZ org
okay yeah great an excellent man thank
you so much for your time appreciate
this a lot okay really great peace
[Music]